hello I'm George Cantor from Carnegie
Mellon University and I'm here to talk
to you about a new way to grow food
world population will reach 9.6 billion
by 2050 sub-saharan Africa is growing
even faster and marginal farmland lack
of water climate change social and
economic issues make food availability
they are difficult our solution we will
breed perennial varieties of key African
crops that survive for several years and
can be repeatedly harvested perennial
staple crops are revolutionary shift
away from current practices this
disruptive approach employing cutting
edge research with open source seed
distribution has the potential to
empower local stakeholders around the
world traditional breeding starts with a
pool of parents that are selected and
crossed to create new varieties that are
grown in field trials the best ones are
kept and the cycle repeats we will add
robotics to provide more accurate
evaluation more quickly so that a
hundred times more candidates can be
tested each year we propose three
integrated efforts first we will create
new perennial crops tuned to local needs
with breeding programs that we establish
in Africa second we will advanced
robotics sensing and information science
necessary for accelerated breeding third
we will work with communities and
national and international organizations
to develop infrastructure and policies
to distribute seeds share best practices
promote local markets and measure the
benefits of new crops partnering with
Clemson and if free we will lead a
diverse team that is committed to
addressing the needs of local farmers to
pioneer a new way to feed the world